zendaya
stunning and bright and yellow at the
2021 oscars
check out the sexy silk chiffon
valentino gown
it's strapless and features a cutout
right in the center zendaya stylist la
roche
shared this behind the scenes video of
zee arriving to the show
oh my gosh she looks so good he also
shared
this snippet showing us that the dress
and jimmy choo's shoes
really are glow in the dark and take a
look at her jewels
la shared this close-up video of the
bulgari bling worth over
6 million dollars he also revealed the
inspiration for the look
it's share circa the share show which
aired in the 70s
during this show zendaya presented the
oscar for best original score
and movies were made for each other
decades before talkies movies
had music they needed music and music
needed them right back
these are the nominees for best score
she also presented the award for best
song when the right song becomes a part
of the right movie
it stays with us forever you can never
hear that song
again without thinking about its movie
partner that
is the power of music although most of
the nominees were able to make it to los
angeles there are a pair joining us from
sweden
so here are the nominees for best song
[Music]